[upbeat music]
female narrator: Better data
drives better decisions,
from improving engagement
to increasing your revenue.
The Google Play
developer console
and Google Analytics can help
you turn your app data
into actionable insights.
Here are ten things
you should be measuring
that will help you build
more successful apps
and market them better.
The user acquisition performance
report in the developer console
gives you a snapshot of how many
users visit your store listing
and install your app.
You can also see the sources
they come from,
whether paid or organic.
The user acquisition performance
report also includes buyer data
so you can see which users
are going on to make purchases
in your app.
You'll see where your most
valuable users come from
and can determine what affects
your installs from each channel,
so you can better understand
where to focus your efforts.
In the developer console's
financial reports,
you can see the average revenue
per paying user, ARPPU,
and understand
how you're generating income.
You can experiment
with changes to your app
and see how
they affect this value.
You can also review data
that helps you understand
how users' spending patterns
in your app change over time.
The metrics we've talked about
so far are all available
in the developer console.
By implementing Google Analytics
in your app
and linking it
to the developer console,
you'll unlock a huge amount
of valuable data
you can analyze and use
to discover useful information,
such as...
User retention rates
are a great indicator
of how well your app will do
long-term.
Google Analytics active users
reports show
how active users remain
in your app,
and you can then look
more deeply
into how you are retaining users
with cohorts reports.
As you identify
which users don't come back,
you can devise tactics
to change that,
from app improvements
to push notifications
to reengagement ads.
Your users' average session
duration
will give you an idea
of how sticky your app is.
Longer session times
may indicate
users are more engaged
with your app
and finding more value
in spending time in it.
You can then compare this data
to how often
users are returning.
You may find they come back
frequently but for short spurts
or they use your app once in
a while but for a long period.
You can now experiment
and measure how app changes
impact on the pattern
of users' visits to your app.
Google Analytics
behavior flow report
can show you which screens
users visit most
and how they move from screen
to screen within your app.
Use this data to improve
and optimize the critical paths
in your app's user experience.
Often, you'll have specific
things you want users to do,
from signing up to a service
to making an in-app purchase,
for example.
These are your conversions.
Google Analytics
lets you define events
and the conversions
you want to track.
By knowing how successful
each event is
at driving conversions,
you can guide users
to the popular events.
If your app sells
physical products or services,
Google Analytics can help you
understand your sales better.
E-commerce reports
and enhanced e-commerce
help you see
which products users buy,
the average order size,
and how long it takes users
to complete purchases.
Analytics lets you track
the lifetime value
of your users' transactions
in your app
by each marketing acquisition
channel.
By understanding which channels
bring in
your most valuable users,
you can adjust your
marketing spend accordingly.
Using the amount that you earn
over the lifetime of a user's
activity in your app,
you can subtract
your per-user cost
to calculate your return
on investment.
From anonymized aggregate data,
understand the different
technology dimensions
to your users,
including what devices they use,
what screen sizes are common,
and what operating system
version they're on.
This will help you optimize
your app design
and test your app against
the right device configurations.
The developer console
and Google Analytics
deliver you the data
and the means to analyze it
so you can gain meaningful
comprehension of your business.
To build up your knowledge
and understand
all the fundamentals
of Google Analytics,
sign up for our self-paced
Analytics Academy course
on mobile app analytics.
If you want more tips
on how to improve your app
or game's performance
and build a better app business,
check out the other videos
in this series
and download The Secrets to App
Success on Google Play.